hey I got a funny voicemail at two one
nine to david p about my pronunciation
of a city in oklahoma take a listen hey
thank you for listening to this i'm
listener and i love your show
i just wanted to let you know that I
watched the episode where Trump was at
Mount Rushmore and said lots of things
incorrectly and when you announced that
he was at Tulsa Oklahoma
you said tool sir so you might wanted to
go back and correct that just so nobody
catches it and says anything bad about
you absolutely delightful voicemail
people will say bad things about me
either way it's just an inside joke
going back to the Tulsi Gabbard Tulsi
days
I'm just mispronouncing it in the same
it's just it's a dumb inside joke and I
apologize if anybody was upset by it but
you know I know that it's pronounced
Tulsa Oklahoma but just to get us back
to the days of the Democratic primary
I've been having a good time calling it
tool stuff but I know that it's Tulsa I
appreciate it anyway okay next Tuesday
David Pakman show chess tournament 8
p.m. Eastern sign up for free today at
david pakman.com slash chess and next
Tuesday one day membership special to
try to recover some of the 300 lost
memberships of the last week get
notified about both the chess tournament
and the membership special by getting on
our newsletter at david pakman.com I'll
see you on the bonus show which are
existing members of course already have
access to